It’s the mission of the century.
A daring rescue into the depths of one of
the most dangerous locations in the multiverse:
Site 13, otherwise known as SCP – 1730.When
the impossible Site 13 was first discovered,
multiple Mobile Task Forces were sent to plumb
its depths and none returned.
They were greeted to a labyrinthine nightmare,
littered with deadly cognitohazards, escaped
SCPs, and mysterious, murderous leeches.
Some were trapped, along with the civilians
they were sent to rescue.
Others were killed or changed in unimaginable
ways.
Mobile Task Force Apollo-3, also known as
“The Game Wardens”, had been sent in on
a rescue mission when they encountered a horrifying
sight: The captured broadcast of Bobble The
Clown, a dangerous SCP known for corrupting
and destroying children through its deadly
messages.
But this Bobble was different.
Much like everything from Site 13, this Bobble
came from an entirely different dimension,
and he had terrifying information to relay:
In the universe where Site 13 originated,
the site’s psychopathic director, one Elliot
Emerson, had struck a deal with the Global
Occult Coalition – a controversial government
group who intends to “protect” humanity
by killing anomalies rather than containing
them.
Emerson had converted his site into an unethical,
unrestrained slaughterhouse, and was incinerating
SCPs by the hundred in a so-called Body Pit.
But Emerson’s game of death came back and
bit him, snapping the threads of reality and
turning the entire site into a dimensionally
displaced super-anomaly.
The Game Wardens realized they were in way
over their heads.
Their chances of surviving this place were
dropping by the second, and if they wanted
any chance of succeeding in their mission,
they needed backup, so Site Command called
in MTF Tau-5, aka “Samsara.”
Calling in Samsara for a run-of-the-mill collection
mission is like using a bazooka to kill a
housefly, but for a case as severe as 1730,
their skills were not only nice to have but
vital.
Samsara are among the best of the best: Immortal
cybernetic clones forged from the flesh of
a god, equipped with weaponry and technology
that could surpass even that of other elite
Mobile Task Force units.
The four members of Samsara are so adept at
what they do that they earned the nickname
“Power Rangers” among their peers.
The remaining Game Wardens knew that with
Samsara on the case, they may actually survive
this thing after all, they just needed to
hold out.
Samsara arrived on site not long after, packing
some serious technological heat – including
arm-mounted incendiary cannons, shock-absorbing
leg extensions, heat-resistant plating, and
built-in SCRAMBLE adaptations within their
eyes to ward off the deadly cognitohazards.
Everyone involved was in for the fight of
their lives.
The four Samsara agents – Irantu, Nanku,
Munru, and Onru – entered via a drainage
gate in one of the office buildings above
ground and began their descent inside.
After observing numerous charred bodies, they
deduced that there must be a massive incinerator
somewhere on site.
Emerson’s incinerator.
Theorizing this was connected to the “Body
Pit” they kept hearing about, they descended
further, feeling the temperature rise as they
did so.
Due to the anomalous nature of 1730, nothing
inside made any kind of logical sense.
Caused by a reality-warping machine known
as THRESHER, the internal geography of Site
13 was subject to constant shifts.
The team then split up to cover more ground
– Munro and Nanku continued to follow the
pipes and the heat towards the furnace, while
Irantu and Onru broke away to explore what
lay beyond a weak wall.
After busting through the wall, Irantu and
Onru explored several empty office blocks
before finding their way into a control room
with a glass observation deck.
While the window was obscured by garbage and
human corpses, signage indicated that the
incinerator and the body pit were directly
below them.
The team once again reconvened, and managed
to activate the incinerator, which shredded
the mass stuck inside with several large turbines
before burning the resulting slurry, the same
process that had happened to so many anomalies
under Emerson’s watch.
With the path cleared, Samsara decided to
descend via the incinerator, using the drainage
pipe as a kind of makeshift tunnel.
Eventually, they happened upon the leeches.
Large, black, and hungry, these creatures
seemed to infest 1730 by the thousand.
Anywhere that blood or drainage runoff could
be found, the leeches could be found, too.
They didn’t appear to have any connection
to an anomaly previously secured and contained
by the Foundation.
They squeezed and wriggled through the cracks
in the walls, searching for fresh blood.
Onru detected that the leeches all moved with
a kind of collective purpose, suggesting a
telepathic hive mind.
Onru was able to tap into this hive mind using
her cybernetic enhancements, and map the chaotic
geography of 1730 through the leech colony’s
collective knowledge.
With this new advantage, they could add a
second goal to this rescue mission: Find the
THRESHER device causing all the instability,
and potentially reduce power to it if possible.
But they were on the clock to save the other
survivors, as those leeches were sure to get
hungry for warm blood soon.
They followed the leeches down the most direct
path towards the survivors.
On the way, they encountered a horrifying
creature: The many-limbed humanoid nightmare
that functions as Emerson’s eternal punishment,
his charred body tied screaming and alive
to the platform where the monster’s head
should be.
They managed to make it past the monster before
finally rendezvousing with Captain Hollis
of Mobile Task Force Zeta-9, otherwise known
as the “Mole Rats”, as well as the Game
Wardens and the other survivors.
There were 27 surviving members of Site 13
staff, many of which had severe injuries – making
it even harder to transport them back to safety
through hazardous terrain.
And to make matters worse, the leeches were
back.
The team quickly decided that the best route
out of here was directly past the THRESHER,
where they could reduce power to the machine
for just long enough to create a stable path
of escape.
Nanku opened fire on a hoard of approaching
leeches with a flamethrower, and everyone
began running for their lives.
It was a final, make-or-break dash to safety.
However, their advance was soon stopped by
a strange, robed creature drawing a cognitohazardous
meme on the wall with its claws.
When the team attempted to engage, it attacked,
exposing additional deadly memes and the dangerous
effects of its single white eye.
And we’re not talking about internet memes
here.
These are symbols and information that are
often deadly to even bear witness to, and
for you or I, this would be a real threat,
but not to a team equipped with goggles containing
cognitohazard filter technology.
The battle was cut short when the floor collapsed
underneath them and this creature was devoured
by something even larger and more monstrous:
A gigantic black leech covered in huge, red
eyes.
Its entrance caused thousands of leeches to
spill out into the hall, as the monster screeched
and slithered its tentacles after them.
Allow us to introduce you to Elijah, also
known as The Leech Boy, and a pivotal component
of the very existence of SCP – 1730.
He was a boy with the mind of a toddler, but
he had the strange ability to absorb blood
through people’s skin – hence his nickname,
“Leech Boy.”
One of the doctors in Site 13, Dr. Hadley,
took pity on Elijah – after all, he didn’t
choose to be the way he was.
Director Emerson didn’t share Hadley’s
sympathy.
His orders to exterminate all anomalies included
humanoids like Elijah.
When Hadley protested, Emerson had her beaten
within an inch of her life while other dissenters
were shot.
Dr. Hadley, disgusted by the inhumanity of
her superiors, devised the perfect revenge.
She sabotaged the incinerator and the body
pit, allowing a mass containment breach that
flooded the site with deadly anomalies.
Young Elijah ended up consuming the slurry
of the other shredded anomalies, causing him
to mutate into a powerful monster, a behemoth
of a leech who gave birth to and controlled
all others.
It was Hadley’s revenge that caused Emerson
to panic and activate THRESHER, leading to
the rift in reality and the creation of 1730,
and – by extension – all the problems
faced by our heroes today.
Samsara and the others fled Leech Boy and
began taking a different escape route.
However, while en route, they encountered
the dreaded Crystal Butterflies – a dangerous
SCP capable of destroying organic matter with
a mere touch.
Irantu stepped up to bat, roasting the creatures
with his arm-mounted incinerator and taking
extreme damage to his body in the process.
But they didn’t have time to rest.
With the butterflies disposed of, they kept
moving, heading towards the THRESHER.
But not all the SCPs were necessarily working
against them.
Bobble the Clown came in handy at the next
checkpoint, manifesting in the monitor of
an electronic door and opening the way through.
As they continued on their journey, they had
to fight off frequent attacks from leeches,
losing some of the task force members in the
process.
They were also forced to face off against
a number of other anomalies in order to survive
– such as SCP – 2316 manifesting as floating
bodies beneath them, and SCP – 1370, which
used a huge, mechanized body to attack the
team of survivors.
That was all just a warm-up for the true final
battle, though.
The floor shattered beneath them, and out
of an impossibly huge chamber, the monster
that had once been Elijah wriggled free – reaching
for them with huge tentacles and shrieking
from its thousand-toothed maw.
It was at least two hundred meters tall, and
barely reacted to any amount of firepower.
It seemed like they were all doomed, until
Captain Hollis had a truly crazy idea.
With the help of Samsara, she led the bloodthirsty
abomination down through the cryonics center
and into an Olympia-class testing chamber.
There, as the Leech Boy was bearing down on
them, Hollis opened the gates to two adjacent
containment cells, and something beyond incredible
happened.
Two of the most powerful SCPs ever known – the
giant, sword-wielding gate guardian, and the
reality bending cosmic deer, SCP – 2845
– entered the arena.
What followed was one of the most epic showdowns
in the history of the SCP Foundation, as the
Deer and the Gate Guardian went to battle
against the all-devouring Leech.
While the monsters fought, Hollis ordered
her team to get the rest of the survivors
to safety.
She and Munru of the Samsara team remained
behind to prevent any of the anomalies from
escaping as the entire base began sinking
into the ground from the combined forces of
the battle raging around them and the THRESHER’s
continued onslaught on reality.
Even if the survivors escaped, would the anomalous
developments inside Site 13 escape and wreak
havoc on the world at large?
That’s when Hollis received a vision, a
horrific, charred, post-apocalyptic world
roamed by inconceivably powerful entities
and nightmare gods.
It was a vision so horrific that just seeing
it nearly broke her mind.
She knew what she had to do – the only way
she could truly defeat this terrible place
and ensure safety for mankind.
While Leech Boy, the Gate Guardian, and the
Deer continued their battle for the ages,
Hollis ran to THRESHER and forced the machine
into overdrive.
Up above, the remaining members of Samsara,
the Mole Rats, and the Game Wardens escorted
the survivors to safety.
Downstairs, THRESHER emitted a blinding white
light as the system began to overload.
In her final moments, all Hollis could do
was laugh – perhaps it was a laugh of pure
insanity, of a mind broken by the horror she
witnessed.
Or perhaps it was a laugh of victory, knowing
that in spite of the immense powers all around
her, she had won the day.
She had saved not only the survivors and her
teammates, but possibly all of humanity.
And all it cost her was everything.
Outside, the survivors had reached a safe
distance when the entirety of Site 13 imploded
in a final brilliant flash.
When the dust cleared SCP-1730 was gone, all
that was left was an immense crater where
the impossible base should have once been.
Captain Hollis had done it – through overloading
the THRESHER machine, she’d taken this anomaly
out of the world the exact same way it had
entered.
It was torn from its moorings on our earth
and kicked into the infinity of spacetime,
perhaps never to be seen again, along with
everything it contained.
SCP – 1730 was reclassified to “neutralized.”
Of course, the Foundation would have plenty
of other anomalies to pursue soon after, but
the nightmare of Emerson’s Site 13 was over
once and for all.